-Keke, Keke, you are up.
Keke, come pull the mic,
and let's see
what challenge you get.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Keke Palmer!
You got this.
[ Beeping ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on.
-Mixtape?
"Opposites Attract."
-♪ This is the game where ♪
♪ Opposites attract ♪
-Now, for this challenge,
you're going to get two songs
with opposite words
in their titles.
You have to sing the lyrics
of one song
over the music
of the other song.
-Oh.
-Let's see what songs you get.
-I don't even understand
what you said.
-Yeah.
-Right.
-You'll understand.
[ Beeping ]
Right. Alright.
-"Don't Start Now," "Don't Stop
Believin'." Okay, I get it.
-Wow. That's actually
pretty clever.
-It's actually good.
Thank you, Will. Yeah.
"So Don't Start Now."
You know Dua Lipa, right?
-Yeah. I love Dua Lipa.
-Yeah, me, too. Alright,
so you have to sing that
over "Don't Stop Believin'."
-Also love Journey. Okay.
-Yeah. You got Journey, as well.
Keke Palmer,
whenever you're ready.
-Let's go, girl.
I know that's right. Yes.
-Band, let's hear it!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ "Don't Stop Believin'"
playing ]
♪♪
-♪ Did a full
one-eighty, crazy ♪
♪ Thinking 'bout the way I was ♪
♪ Did the heartbreak
change me? Maybe ♪
♪ But look at where I ended up ♪
♪ I'm all good already,
so moved on, it's scary ♪
♪ I'm not where
you left me at all, so ♪
♪ So if you don't wanna see me
dancing with somebody ♪
Hey.
♪ If you wanna believe
that anything could stop me ♪
-Freakin' amazing.
-How is she doing this?
♪♪
-♪ Don't show up,
don't come out ♪
♪ Don't start caring
about me now ♪
♪ Walk away, you know how ♪
♪ Don't start caring ♪
♪ About me now ♪
-♪ 'Bout me now ♪
-♪ Don't show up ♪
-♪ Don't come out ♪
♪ Don't start caring
about me now ♪
♪ Walk away ♪
-♪ Walk away ♪
-♪ You know how ♪
♪ Don't start caring
about me now ♪
♪ Don't stop believin' ♪
-I know that's right, girl!
-♪ Hold on to that feelin' ♪
♪ Streetlights, people ♪
-I know that's right!
-Oh, my gosh! Oh, my gosh!
Stop it! Stop it!
Oh, my gosh!
That was unbelievable!
Standing ovation, come on, now.
-That's my partner right there.
-Oh, my God!